what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
oh my goodness Marvel generations man
dude this story is actually really
really fun it's really cool the one
thing about generations for those of you
guys who are new to the Marvel landscape
at the moment Marvel is initiating
something called legacy which is
basically whether bringing back a lot of
the older characters that seem to
basically exist side by side with new
characters which is kind of cool like
riri williams is one of my favorite
characters it's out there right now um
definitely Amadeus Cho Hulk because it's
just like a super smart hook the idea
here is that this is designed to find
the sort of middle ground between those
that don't want things to change whether
classic superheroes to stay and those
that want new superheroes and so what
this does is it kind of brings like greg
packs view of the Incredible Hulk kind
of all the way back to really the very
beginning well the funny thing about
this is a Greg Pak I would say is
probably one of the most interesting
writers when it came to the Incredible
Hulk I don't know if he'd be the most
important just because there were
writers before him that established some
pretty important things Peter David guys
like that that established the idea are
really built on the idea that Bruce
Banner I guess the Incredible Hulk
personality emerged as a result of all
the abuse that Bruce Banner suffered
when he was a kid at the hands of his
father but with Greg Pak he basically
took the Incredible Hulk concept as we
knew him and he basically just built on
the Incredible Hulk smashing stuff idea
and so that's where the original Planet
Hulk that's where World War Hulk all
that stuff that's where it really all
just kind of came in together to create
this giant Hulk myth though so it's
really one of the coolest runs in recent
years so I would argue if anybody is
best suited to write a Marvel generation
story on the Incredible Hulk it's
probably Greg Pak says he's been one of
the most influential writers in recent
years but the other thing about this is
that this simply just picks up with
Amadeus Cho Hawk now we don't know how
he got here that that explanation is
never really given to us the idea is
that it gives us a little bit of an
explanation about his character but only
insofar that he had basically cured
quote-unquote Bruce Banner of the
Incredible Hulk by absorbing the
Incredible Hulk essence into himself and
then in turn becoming the Hulk this is
kind of a cool thing is because when
Amadeus Cho did that it wasn't like Greg
Pak just kind of pulled it out of
nowhere a precedence had been set in a
multitude of different ways case in
point there's been stories were Bruce
Banner in the Incredible Hulk have been
split there's been times were like
during the onslaught saga for example
where Jean Grey established that Bruce
Banner and The Incredible Hulk are
indeed two different persona
living in the same body one can be
suppressed and the other can reign
supreme we've seen stories like what
we're Hulk we're both of their ideals
align and The Incredible Hulk just goes
absolutely berserk on the earth
superhero so it's not really a new thing
this is kind of an established thing the
funny thing about this is that getting
into it
what is up happening is that with
Amadeus Cho just kind of being here not
really knowing exactly where he is
he ends up stumbling into the Incredible
Hulk just being attacked by the armies
of general Thunderbolt Ross now again
Marvel generations exists for the
purpose of basically giving new readers
kind of a jumping on point and what I
mean by that is with the Incredible Hulk
especially with his character a lot of
people know the concept of the Hulk
which is to say Bruce Banner gets angry
and he becomes the Hulk but the nuanced
aspects of them are things that are just
kind of left out there that they're not
a hundred percent sure about general
Thunderbolt Ross always chasing after
the Incredible Hulk that's kind of been
a hallmark of his character different
things like that but again this is
really kind of cool because this again
focuses on seeing the world of The
Incredible Hulk through the eyes of
banner as Amadeus Cho is watching it
unfold now the reason why this is kind
of important is because Amadeus Cho was
a relatively new character in Marvel
Comics I mean he's not super old he
hasn't been around for like thirty years
he's been around for a pretty good chunk
of time but with Amadeus Cho he was very
much his own character he was really
just kind of a character who was out
there that existed alongside the
Incredible Hulk who is really one of the
only people The Incredible Hulk
actually was friends with in a lot of
different ways outside of Rick Jones and
so it made sense that there would be a
natural transition that if Bruce Banner
was going to go away Amadeus Cho would
take his place and so the result is that
with Amadeus Cho watching these events
unfold really for the first time he's
experiencing what it's like to see Bruce
Banner as the Hulk as a Hulk himself and
that's why this is kind of important
because it's one thing to see the idea
of Hulk freaking out when you're Amadeus
Cho and you're just a normal guy it's
another to walk in his shoes and that's
really the crux of this whole story now
a funny moment here is that when the
Incredible Hulk slashing out when the
incredible hooks freaking out Amadeus
Cho starts to kind of analyze and look
around and say okay cool they're
unmanned we can go ahead and attack them
you can go ahead you don't have to worry
about holding back and the whole tree
sponsors like what wasn't gonna hold
back anyway whether they were manned or
unmanned they were all gonna get
destroyed so it's kind of funny I mean
this is kind of the cool thing here
because this is like classic Bruce
Banner Hulk because that's the nature of
his character
like people don't usually read The
Incredible Hulk when they go to pick up
an Incredible Hulk story they don't
necessarily read Bruce Banner Hulk for
the purpose of seeing Bruce Banner Hulk
as a super intelligent guy they read
Amadeus Cho hook for that when it comes
to Bruce Banner Hulk they just want to
see him smash stuff now of course this
inevitably leads to the Incredible Hulk
attempting to attack civilians and
that's the difference here is because
Amadeus Cho as a member of the champions
as a superhero looks to the Incredible
Hulk ideology as a means to an end where
Bruce Banner looked at the Incredible
Hulk and simply said well you know I
mean this is just kind of a curse and
I'm stuck with and I can't control it
Amadeus Cho can control his
transformations and so the Incredible
Hulk or at least the whole concept when
it belongs to Cho is tantamount to like
a shovel or a pitchfork it's a tool to
achieve a goal and so for him going
through and just attacking civilians
whether they're attacking the Hulk or
not is not okay because all lives are
important now the idea here is that with
Amadeus Cho basically stopping Hulk it
leads to the two of them fighting one
another now this is kind of interesting
here because with Amadeus Cho he is not
on par with classic banner hawk with
classic banner Hulk it's a totally
separate mindset and so for him it's
just he's gonna keep fighting until he
wins he'll just keep getting angrier and
angrier and angrier until he wins the
only exception to that is if the Hulk is
fighting a being that's so incredibly
powerful that he can just immediately
overcome the Incredible Hulk before he
can get angry enough to withstand that
foes physical attacks or if that person
is just some Universal constructs they
would just phase the Hulk out of
existence or something along those lines
with Amadeus Cho he's not on that level
his unlimited strength he's not quite
where savage Hulk classic banner Hulk
whatever you want to call him were
traditionally used to seeing him and so
on the whole Amadeus Cho is able to hold
his own to a degree but ultimately the
Incredible Hulk really just keeps coming
and coming and coming now of course this
leads to a stalemate for the most part
with regards to Amadeus Cho it is kind
of fighting him to the point where he's
like all right look I'm not gonna attack
you anymore now what this does is it
kind of brings into sharp relief the
nature of the whole because while the
Hulk is a force of nature in a lot of
different ways it doesn't mean that he's
simply going to attack with no real
cause and if the threat is basically
subdued the Hulk will chill out at the
same time this is not tried-and-true
savage hulk and the difference here is
that the Incredible Hulk has a lot of
different personas a lot of different
concepts to his character a lot of
different mindsets there's professor
holt which is basically
genius version of The Incredible Hulk
there's world war hulk who's at his most
powerful form but capable of rational
thought this is a more toned down
version savage Hulk is just Hulk who's
just raging out just absolutely losing
his mind you can't really form complex
sentences he's really more of just like
a simple creature that just has an
incredible amount of strength as opposed
to a guy with any real measure of
thought but what is up happening is that
in this time where this stalemate takes
place they both basically end up you
know powering down for a lack of a
better word now remember Amadeus Cho as
it stands right now in this story is
recollecting the events of Civil War 2
it's more or less takes place or at
least it seems to take place in the
present day with regards to Amadeus Cho
the problem with this is that we're not
given a time frame because of the fact
that Amadeus Cho just showed up here and
because Bruce Banner doesn't know who he
is the implication is that maybe Amadeus
Cho was thrown into the past now the
reason why this sort of works is because
remember the generations is designed to
basically follow up two secret Empire
but secret Empire is not finished yet
Marvel does kind of had to throw these
out there for the sake of just getting
numbers up and you know getting the
sales going and all that kind of good
stuff keeping interest in Marvel Comics
so we don't really know exactly how it
is that secret Empire will lead into
legacy generations that kind of a thing
we just know that it will now most
likely in like legacy or something along
those lines there will basically be a
point whereby it'll explain how it is
that Amadeus Cho got here in the first
place but at the very least you know we
can just kind of take this up chalk it
with a grain of salt and say okay maybe
he's in the past if Rouge banner doesn't
know who he is and Bruce Banner is
currently alive it makes sense that this
is some time in the past because
remember during the events of Civil War
two Hawkeye had basically killed Bruce
Banner at the request of banner himself
when Hawkeye was warned that if banner
ever hooks out to basically take the
measure of killing him and so the result
is that Amadeus chose kind of wrestling
with this idea
do I tell Bruce Banner that he's going
to die but the thing about this is that
this leads into a really important
discussion between Bruce Banner and
Amadeus Cho and what this does is it
sets the stage for the future of The
Incredible Hulk
going into generations and you know
whatever it is it comes after that what
is up happening here his banner sustain
and basically gives Cho his perspective
of the Hulk in terms of how he views the
Hulk how he views himself in relation to
the Hulk what he recalls about his life
different things like that now this
whole little bit of an explanation
regarding Bruce banners father beating
with regards to Bruce banners father
beating his mother and then in turn
killing the mother of Bruce Banner again
that goes all the way back to the old
school origin of a Bruce Banner himself
this has long since been established but
what is up happening here is that Bruce
Banner basically makes the case that the
Incredible Hulk
is one of the most destructive forces in
existence and indeed he is as The
Incredible Hulk Bruce Banner is
terrified of what he could do I mean we
saw with world war hawk that if the
Incredible Hulk got angry enough and he
stomped on the ground he shook the
entirety of the eastern seaboard is it
that far out of the realm of belief to
really kind of assume the Incredible
Hulk could destroy the world if the
Incredible Hulk is at his absolute peak
who's gonna be able to bring him down
and world war hulk it was a combination
of tony stark satellites and the century
but if the Hulk continued to keep
getting angrier and angrier and angrier
no one would be able to stand in his way
and so again this is what Bruce Banner
is afraid of the Incredible Hulk is
always just one heartbeat away from
laying waste to everything they care
about now the funny thing about this is
that in the middle of their discussion
this small cities basically set upon by
this giant beast thing and of course
they end up beating it it's kind of a
weird turn to take in this story but
Greg Pak does that a lot where he's just
kind of like hey here's something
interesting and then here's a weird
thing out of nowhere but in the middle
of all this the reason why this is kind
of important is because Amadeus Cho is
both being attacked by this massive
monster with Bruce Banner trying to
escort people out and at the same time
being attacked by the forces of general
Thunderbolt Ross he's are literally
being hit on all sides and in this
moment amadeus cho basically cuts loose
and then just loses it and when he does
he effectively becomes savage hulk now
this is a blink of an eye moment it
happens so fast that if you're not
paying attention you'll miss it and so
with regards to this what is up
happening is Bruce Banner turns back
into the Incredible Hulk or The
Incredible Hulk tree emerges and the two
of them begin engaging in a conflict
again now this is the other side of the
Incredible Hulk with Amadeus Cho able to
control his transformations the desire
of Bruce Banner was to figure out how to
do that if he could control his
transformations he could decide when the
Incredible Hulk can and cannot come out
because remember the Incredible Hulk
just kind of pops up sometimes at the
most inopportune times sometimes at the
most opportune times but with the
Incredible Hulk basically taunting him
saying hey look you've got a monster
inside of you whether you
know it or not but you have no real
genuine answers you've got no legitimate
explanations on how to solve this crime
Meyer he ends up just kind of
transforming into Val you know back in
the Bruce Banner and Bruce Banner
continues the discussion and saying yes
amadeus cho is a good kid yes amadeus
cho wants to do the right thing but
Bruce Banner started out the same way
when Bruce Banner first realized that he
was becoming the Incredible Hulk this
dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde scenario for him it
was the desire to control and contain
the Incredible Hulk
and only ever let him out when the Hulk
was needed when the Avengers were
fighting or something along those lines
but as time progressed the Incredible
Hulk would just keep popping up and it
became clear very very fast The
Incredible Hulk is his own personality
that he just kind of comes out and then
does what he wants to now again a lot of
this is circumstance but with this
statement what Bruce Banner says is the
power that we possess is an incredibly
destructive force we are basically
jailers were prison guards we're not
really superheroes and that's true
that's kind of the cool thing about this
that was always the biggest fear will
The Incredible Hulk come out and if he
does what will happen that was the basis
behind the entire Planet Hulk event in
the first place the Illuminati these
self-proclaimed protectors of the world
they had basically all come together and
said hey look we need to protect the
Earth from the Incredible Hulk and if we
cannot separate banner in the Hulk then
we'll just get rid of them both and they
symptom offworld now of course this led
into the whole Planet Hulk story itself
but that highlights the very nature of
the story kind of coming full circle in
the sense that the Incredible Hulk stew
unpredictable The Incredible Hulk is too
dangerous in the Incredible Hulk is too
powerful to just be assumed to be a
benign entity and so the warning sign
that Bruce Banner gives to Amadeus Cho
really the the warning he gives off here
is that a time is going to come
something's going to take place when
Amadeus Cho is going to lose control and
when he does this Incredible Hulk
persona this Cho hope that he's been
running around as for a while is gonna
be replaced and it's gonna become savage
Hawk and when it does this savage Hawk
is gonna take on its own personality
it's gonna take on its own role and the
result is gonna lead into Amadeus Cho
basically just kind of becoming the very
thing he doesn't want to be in so again
this sets the stage for this sort of
coming together of these two different
iterations of these characters Bruce
Banner warning Amadeus Cho trying to
guide him in the right direction and
Amadeus Cho trying to make sure he does
not become this Savage
that he's so terrified of but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain and make
sure you guys said the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like this continues I believe in the
Incredible Hulk number 709 which is
weird
I'll explain Marvel legacy numbering at
some point actually no we can do it here
all this really means when it comes to
legacy numbering is that with characters
like The Incredible Hulk there was the
original Incredible Hulk one through six
and then he's just had different solo
series the legacy numbering simply means
that with issue number of 709 it just
means that overall there have been seven
hundred and eight issues of The
Incredible Hulk
the one coming out after this will be
issue number 709 that's all that means
when it comes to legacy member not
confusing it all pretty simple to follow
if you've been reading comics I kind of
wish they'd taken it back to the day
what they used to do they did it with
the Fantastic Four they did it with Thor
what they used to do is you would go
pick up those little comics and it would
be like Thor you know it would be issue
22 slash 206 and what that would mean is
that it's the twenty second issue of the
current run but the two hundred and
second as two hundred six issue overall
I mean that those numbers I'm just kind
of pulling out of thin air but you guys
understand what I'm saying I kind of
wish they've done that that I think
would have been a smarter road to take
just because they're publishing so many
comics with legacy memory but
nonetheless guys we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you